good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
messages learn how to sell over to you
Robert Kiyosaki I am very shy very very
shy and I came back from Vietnam and I
could kill people but I couldn't talk to
people and one day I said to my mom I
decided to follow my rich dad's
footsteps that just said to him I want
to be an entrepreneur he says you got
one problem I said what's that so if
you're shy I said what's wrong with
being shy he says you gotta sell you got
to handle rejection number one skill can
you handle rejection answers no I
couldn't handle it so I stole it while
we're having cell so now this is the
1973 I was 25 years old and my Rich Dad
said how's your love life so it sucks
she's getting laid I said no so because
you can't sell guys got it so when I
talk about what skill do you need when
this hits the fan
you better start selling so I went to
work for Xerox in 1974 so I can learn
how to sell took me four years and I was
number one okay and today I'm a
best-selling author
you know most PhD is telling me I can't
write yes I said I can't write but I
can't sell if you can't sell you don't
make money period and the statement you
know just because you have a product
doesn't mean jack but the important
thing is you start you know I don't care
what product you start with but you
start you know I started off with dialog
wallets success wiped me out you know we
couldn't sell couldn't sell also they
took off then I couldn't finance I
couldn't finance to put in finance
because the sales kept going through the
roof now trouble is I can't borrowing
and it couldn't sustain the sales next
lesson but that's how we learn so I'm
not as hardcore as Robert is about sales
and in hard selling as a skill that is
the most important thing to learn
because that is one way to stand if you
want to be great at sales it is a
fantastic way to build a business but
it's not the only way there are a lot of
shy entrepreneurs myself included who
have had success people who you've never
heard of because they're shy and they
just found another way to stay and so
again if sales is your thing is your
forte or something that you want to
focus on to be great at then go for it
cuz it's definitely great way to do it
but again it's not the only way when I
took over this business strongly in
salsa i sat down with Alex we looked at
ten different ways to grow the business
and I had him pick the two that he
really wanted to focus on I gave him one
which is be a thought leader and then
okay pick the one that you want to focus
on is it going to be one of them was
sales one of them was okay let's go in
and start selling people and start
making partnerships with with different
businesses and say hey how do we have
these Alliance things work out where you
can promote our classes to your
customers and we find some kind of
arrangement to make the work out he
focused on something now
so you want to focus on providing a
great customer experience you know
that's one way to say it if you provide
a fantastic customer experience they
will come back and they will tell their
friends and Alex came from a sales
background at a different job so my
initial thinking was okay we're gonna
have a Salesman come in and go and sell
and it switched to okay we're gonna
focus on having a great customer
experience because they're gonna tell
their friends and they're gonna come
back and be repeat buyers so that's
another way to stand it could be you
provide great marketing it can be you
build the team and you allow the people
underneath you to bring their skills in
it could be you're doing a thought
leader it could be going through PR
could be going through influencers it
doesn't have to be the traditional hard
core sales approach now the one thing
that all of these things have in common
that if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur and be a leader you're
gonna have to figure out is how to
connect with people and if you want to
see sales as connecting with people I'm
okay with that
it's just not the typical salesman
approach of you know I see that person
as my next suit or as you know I got to
hit my sales quota and I'm gonna force
them to buy this thing a lot of times
sales the scenes of that lens if you see
it as just connecting with people and
helping them along their path the
difference for me is really doing the
thing that is best for them we're a lot
of times in sales you're just trying to
hit your quarter you're just trying to
reach your mark you're trying to you
know push to come the customer past
their comfort zone so you can meet your
sales quota so it's a very selfish
perspective as opposed to this is
actually what's best for them but if you
want to form alliances if you want to
talk to the media if you want to be a
great leader if you want to be a thought
leader if you want to write great
marketing copy you want to stand out on
social media you have to be able to
understand how to connect with people
and move them to take action is in their
best interest I just want to let people
know that it's okay to be shy if you are
shy you can have a lot of success as an
entrepreneur you can have a lot of
success in a lot of different fields you
know Ellen is an introvert which
surprised me but as you know the biggest
talk show on TV there's lots of
different ways of staying it's not that
this is the only way to have success as
an
burner you know it works for some people
that's not gonna work for you and the
worst thing you can do the worst thing
you can do is say listen to somebody who
doesn't look like you it doesn't believe
the same things as you and listen to
them saying this is the only way to do
it and then feel like you can't measure
up and you can't be like them and so
you'll never have success and you'll try
and try and try but you will never beat
through because you're just not enough
like them
we're the best thing you can do is find
someone who looks like you find someone
who's accomplished success that believes
the same thing as you that has the same
kind of personality as you and be able
to learn from them and say like they did
it they had success as a shy
entrepreneur they had successes of
introverted entrepreneur so I can have
it too and so wherever you draw the line
between sales and be able to connect
with people because this is super super
super important and if you see them
that's the same thing that's great but
if she is the Hardcore you don't have to
go down that path and you can't have
success if you are shy so the question
today today is I'm curious how shy are
you and how do you define sales do you
see sales the typical salesman who is
just trying to meet their quarter or you
see sales as trying to connect the
people to help move them to take some
kind of action really curious to hear
your thoughts leave down the comments
below and also if you leave a comment
within the first couple hours of this
video going live you have a chance to
play in one of our two daily prizes I
also want to give a quick chart atubu to
van Hecke thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word I
really really really appreciate it and I
hope you're enjoying the read thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
Express Oh give me go
entrepreneur not a salesperson I'm not
just an entrepreneur we look at the
start of business well if you can't sell
if you can't influence if you can't
persuade good luck trying to get your
business off the ground I'm not just
your customers I'm talking about the
bankers the people are venture
capitalists your vendors your credit
card processor the people who work for
you how do you get people to work for
you excited how do you get them excited
to get them to want to buy into your
vision at the highest level what sales
really is the transference of emotion
and the emotion you're transferring is
this emotion of certainty that don't
feel certain yet it's a good thing
that's gonna help me it's gonna fill my
need when you're an entrepreneur you're
trying to start a business and you're
recruiting people well you're selling
people on your vision for the future
your vision for this company if you
can't do that good luck trying to get
great people to work for you it's very
it's almost it's nearly impossible which
is why you what we see you know the
people if they say oh he's a visionary
well that's true but typically not only
are they visionaries they also possess
the ability to sell the vision to other
people to inspire them to motivate them
so selling is not just like you know
people think of selling oh well a lot of
salesmen I don't he thought well yes you
do you need to learn how to influence
how not trying to get your kids to make
their bed or do that homework or believe
in the value of education how about
trying to get a landlord give you a
reduction on your rent ought to extend
the lease of the way you want how about
trying to negotiate terms you understand
it's it cuts to everything so I always
looking to say you know when I say I
cracked the code on influence what I
really did essentially was I just I was
you know by working backwards almost by
saying imma start at the end and go to
the beginning say what has to happen
before someone says yes I was able to
take that and put it into this system
that took the no-name talentless guys
and turn them into millionaires selling
is something you'll always do the rest
of your life most people don't like
selling some people like to kind of make
it nice and sound we use a better word
and say communication or diss its sales
by the way those that just turn off the
video and don't want to watch about what
selling has to do hey you want to marry
that girl you love you know which one
I'm talking about you need to sell her
and her parents and her best friend
that's all selling you want to get that
promotion purely selling baby and
to get that promotion sell better than
you do that's why it is they don't sell
a car their job could be human resource
or something but they learn how to sell
themselves as that position more than
you maybe you oughta learn how to do
it'll benefit you make you a lot of
money